Hi! We want to let you know about this cool event:
This Saturday, we are invited to a pair ask
me anything (AMA) session with Sanyam and me.
And guess whom we'll have as a host:
It's Dr. Bryan Bischof, the Head of
Data Science at Weights & Biases.
And because Sanyam runs the Chai Time
Data Science Podcast (awesome, btw),
we will have an epic fight
between Chai and Coffee!
And of course, we will also talk about
educational content, about videos,
about the AI and ML communities in general.
So, Ms. Coffee Bean, are we up for it?
Of course we are. But are you?
Bring your chai or coffee and
join us this Saturday at 5 PM CET,
which is 8 AM PT (Pacific Time).
Find the link and details to the
event in the video description.
Btw, new AI Coffee Break video
dropping in hot this week.